beging welcome to the studio big victory
for you with the black pieces this was
not a easy start to this tournament
because you had double black what was
the strategy yesterday and today and by
the way yesterday you had a great
position as well so things seem to be
going your way how are you feeling right
now hi guys um yeah to double black it
was a little bit uh hard hard to prepare
because I didn't know what to expect
some
you know most of the players it feels
like prepared new openings and I didn't
get anything that I prepared in two days
so I'm kind of happy I survived with one
and a half points and yeah yesterday I
had some chances but I don't know I
calculated something's wrong I feel like
and missed it unfortunately tell us
about today's game um did she surprise
you in the opening with this exchange
ruy Lopez and uh how did do you approach
the ensuing position were you happy with
a draw at that point or were you trying
for
more I was trying for more of course
when she took Bishop uh C6 I was like
okay I have two Bishops and uh most
probably I'm going to win the game
somehow uh I just didn't expect I knew
she could play Bishop B5 but of course I
didn't expect Bishop B5 and Bishop C6
from her especially she lost yesterday
so I thought she's going to try to fight
back mhm so
I just made some moves so her strategy
her uh let's say peaceful strategy
surprised you a little
bit yeah I mean I was happy about it you
have two Bishops comfortable position
it's not like uh I forgot all these
lines that existed right I just knew
some things I put to pieces and uh tried
to just play the game and I really like
the way you continued your attack and
expansion on both sides a H5 but also A4
B4 and you were putting a lot of
pressure and it was at this moment when
you broke through Bishop to B3 Bishop to
C2 and now there's no way for her to
keep control in the position uh was that
the moment when you felt like finally
you get that decisive
Advantage actually I was mad at Bishop
C2 I knew that I saw something and I
forgot I had 5 minutes I'm like wait a
sec why am I giving why am I allowing C4
what I'm going what I'm going to do now
then I I'm like oh Rook A6 idea was Rook
D6 and Rook D4 somehow yes in that case
so I just played Bishop f8 but I wasn't
sure what kind of position position is
it feels like if uh White is able to put
Bishop B2 and Rook C1 they they they're
fine so I wasn't sure uh Rook C Rook
instead of night how the game ends yeah
for example like
G4 I got luy that I have Bishop D1 here
oo that's a nice move Rook takes D1 and
Rook takes if I was like Temple down she
should be fine yeah I think because of
this move my position was fine yeah and
after that uh you ended up in style with
this move King to D7 trying to set up
the mating net Beautiful Finish begging
congratulations and nice jacket I think
yaser wants
one I'll fight for it
B congratul coach can get you one all
right uh our congratulations good luck
in the rest of the tournament thank you
thank you guys